LAURA LING: So
Doctor Carson, this
is the historic
March on Washington,
of which you were a part.
Can we see you in here?
CLAYBORNE CARSON: I was
probably right about there.
LAURA LING: About 250,000
people marched on Washington
in August, 1963, including
civil rights activist Clayborne
Carson.
It was one of many protests
against segregation
and other forms of legal
discrimination during that era.
CLAYBORNE CARSON:
I was 19 years old.
I didn't tell my
parents I was going .
For me, this was an event
that was long overdue.
LAURA LING: was that
sense of urgency.
CLAYBORNE CARSON:
Definately, yeah.
And that's what King spoke
to, was the urgency of now.
There comes a time when
people get frustrated
at the slow pace of change.
LAURA LING: Today, more
than 50 years later there
seems to be a new
sense of urgency.
Images and videos of Mike Brown,
Eric Garner, Sandra Bland,
Freddie Gray, and
others sent shock waves
through communities
across the country
and inspired a new generation
of activists demanding justice.
SAMUEL SINYANGWE: And one of
the moments that really hit home
for me was when Trayvon
Martin was killed
and George Zimmerman
was acquitted.
I saw myself in Trayvon Martin.
I was the kid who,
every single day,
would walk home, stop at
7-Eleven, buy some candy
and a sweet tea.
The reality that, at any moment,
somebody could have come up
attacked and killed me,
and the justice system
wouldn't have done anything.
It hit home.
LAURA LING: 25-year-old
Sam Sinyangwe works
with a team called
We the Protesters
to organize activists and to use
social media to affect change.
Sam, you tweeted,
Last year there
were protests over 100 cities.
That hasn't happened since 1965.
It's a new civil
rights movement, folks.
What would you say is different
about today's civil rights
movement?
SAMUEL SINYANGWE: One
big key difference
is the use of technology.
How technology's
been an instrumental
tool in bringing folks together
and scaling the work at a pace
that really was
unheard of in the '60s.
The year since Mike
Brown has been killed
has seen over three times
as many protests happening
as 1965.
And so this is a
scale that really is
unheard of in American history.
LAURA LING: Can you talk
to me about organizing back
in the 1960s?
How did people organize an
effective grassroots movement?
CLAYBORNE CARSON:
Mainly face to face.
And the main electronics
we used were telephones.
In fact, the Student Non-violent
of Coordinating Committee
developed what they
called the WATS Line.
And all it really was
was a way of making
inexpensive long-distance
telephone calls.
LAURA LING: A WATS, or wide
area telephone service line,
allowed civil rights workers
to report threats or violence
happening on the ground.
Typed reports of
those calls would
be delivered to movement
leaders and the press.
CLAYBORNE CARSON: That
was a major transformation
in the movement.
Social movements always use
the technology of their day
to the maximum, because
social movements are all about
communicating to people.
That's still happening today.
The only thing that's different
is that it's much faster.
LAURA LING: Sam is
also using public data
to track and map
instances of police
violence across the country.
SAMUEL SINYANGWE:
We've learned things
that communities have been
saying for a long time.
We've mapped 336 black people
killed by police in 2015,
313 were killed
by police in 2014.
Because of the Internet,
we're able to actually gather
this data in a way
that actually ended up
being much more comprehensive
than the federal government has
ever been able to do.
LAURA LING: What do you
think Doctor King would
think about the Black Lives
Matter movement for example?
CLAYBORNE CARSON:
I think he would
be very appreciative
of the fact whenever
young people are concerned about
things other than themselves.
That's a positive sign.
I think he would of thrived
in this kind of an age.
He would have been very, very
open to using social media.
He would have had millions
of followers on Twitter .
LAURA LING: Are you hopeful?
SAMUEL SINYANGWE: Absolutely.
We've seen over 1,000
protests take place.
We seen hundreds of
thousands of people engage.
We've seen 24 states
signed legislation
to improve police
accountability.
We've seen the President take
executive action in order
to address police brutality.
All that work has happened in
space of a little over a year.
This is a moment of
tremendous opportunity,
but it is not something
that is preordained.
It is something that
could all be taken away,
and we could go backwards.
And so we have to keep fighting.
LAURA LING: Has the
Internet encouraged
you to become more politically
engaged in the offline world?
Tell us some in
the comments below,
and check out this next video
about a superintendent who
transformed a school
district in a poor community
outside Saint Louis.
SUBJECT: If all you can
do is make it to school,
we'll take care of the rest.
Food, clothes,
shoes, health care.
LAURA LING: What
kind of changes did
you start to see
in your students
when you started to
remove those barriers?
SUBJECT: So when kids
knew that we cared,
there was almost like
this light bulb went off,
this willingness to try.
LAURA LING: Thanks for
watching, and please subscribe
for more Seeker Stories.